en période de fêtes le berrichon se
transforme vite en ambassadeurs
lentilles et truffes sont les étendards
de marie madeleine
elle défend issoudun faire connaître sa
région et surtout l'indre qui est encore
plus mal connu que le cher le grand noir
du berry le pense que c'en est des
chocolats noirs
voilà c'est pour apporter à des gens
qu'ils ont pas dit si oui un parisien
dans cette boutique spécialisée
la liste s'allonge d'année en année avec
des références surprenantes à côté du
maine tout salon et du sancerre le vin
on trouve des bières du jean et même du
whisky fabriqués dans le cher du raisin
macéré dans le vin de s'en servent de
sauternes et enrobés de chocolat plein
plein plein de petits producteurs qui
font plein de bonnes choses des pattes
du quinoa ans les gens veulent se faire
plaisir et par les papilles c'est encore
le mieux quoi et certains produits sont
victimes de leur succès une livraison de
croquer et de terrines est attendue dans
les heures qui viennent
les gens ont beaucoup beaucoup acheté et
du coup le magasin commencé à se vider
voilà mais on arrive à gérer l'estac
quand même sous les halles saint bonnet
la fromagerie fournit d'autres
ambassadeurs berrichon aussi gourmand et
motiver les gens l'emportent ils les en
l'envoi par qu'un avion aussi quand ils
viennent dans la région et remporte à
leur famille donc souvent où il emmène
des grosses quantités de fromage de
crottin
cinq morts tout ce qui est cher en fait
pouligny-saint-pierre wallon sait rien
de belles histoires pour faire découvrir
les produits du berry acquis à bas un
peu partout en terre montoise
rohannec'h programme s'appelle voilà si
les berrichons font voyager leurs
spécialités
c'est pour attirer les touristes ici
dans le berry